hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game from the 2020
chasuble masters that really kind of
shows us why rapid chess is sometimes
better than classical what I mean by
this will be revealed it very shortly so
without further ado it's Yanni Pony
versus Fabiana Korra wanna again two
contenders of the 2020 candidates
tournament as this is Group B of the
chest Bowl masters so let's see what
happens here nappa opens with E for now
and Fabi goes for e5 we have night of
390 to c6 and of course the Royal Lopez
is on the board so the ship to b5 we
have a six and now Bishop to a four nine
if six of everything fairly standard we
have castles and Bishop to c5 what
hobbies playing a lot lately we've see
three and now preparing to strike in the
center would be four and five e castles
and here we have d4 so you could just
move the bishop you could capture but no
one no one ever captures it's not the
way to go so usually you go push it back
to a7 or better back to be six so here
father goes for Bishop to b6 and Bishop
to g5 now just nicely painting the
denied and you can see that white has a
very natural development like the the
pawns are occupying the center deny the
bishops are nicely developed here the
the knight is nicely developed this
night might come to d2 later - maybe f1
to g3 or e3 so very normal development
we have h6 by Fabi asking do you want to
capture you want to go back to e3 do
want to go back to h4 nipple decides
that he wants to keep the tension he
doesn't want to unpin here and these six
now are preparing to develop with maybe
Bishop to Bishop to g4 as you don't
really have all that many good squares
you can't go here this is possible you
can't go to east six because of just b5
so here there are a couple of moves that
are known in this position like d5 Queen
b3 is a known move bunch of characters
and c6 is a known move but the move
nipple place is a new move so already as
of move 10 we have a completely new game
so he prevents Fabi from developing the
Bishop to g4 and the Fabi now asks well
okay I cannot develop my Bishop to g4
but what's preventing me from capturing
an e4 okay you're better but what if I
play g5 can I just play g5 Bishop g3
the gobble of this e4 pawn well perhaps
and Fabi knows what's happening if he
plays g5 and he accepts the challenge so
here father plays g5 and now nip of
course if he just moves the bishop he
loses the pawn but his plan was to
sacrifice a piece for two points all
along
so Knight characters and g5 with each
character's and Bishop captures and now
you've sacrificed for the attack you
have a nice grip on the position this
Knight cannot move the Queen is here it
will be very very difficult to unpin
usually black ball goes on like King g7
Kings to h7 try and bring the rook into
the game and maybe then bring the King
back to safety so here there are a
couple of options you could choose from
you could go let's say King to g7 the
engine is giving some very very sneaky
lines King g7 and even to g6 there to go
after the bishop and then bring the rook
into the game Fabi whoever chooses King
to h7 and now he wants to use the semi
open G file to attack the white king
which makes sense he's already up a
piece he might do some like Ruby Jade
Bishop captures on h3 and you know good
things could happen
so here rush of characters and c6 by
nipple first eliminating this guy here
and now the problem is a Fabi cannot
recapture if you recapture then you have
captures on e5 and white wins because if
you capture then just the Queen captures
rook characters and you capture and f6
you win back your piece and you are up
to pawns in a much better position so
this would be a no-go for Fabi so here
after Bishop captures on c6 Fabi said
okay I'm I was already up a piece so
it's not a problem
rook g8 and now Napo has to decide what
to do if he decides for someone like
Bishop characters and Queen captures
then you still have to decide what to do
with the bishop here your Bishop is
under attack now you don't want to give
it up so if Bishop d5 then it's just a
really strong position for black let's
say Queen h4 now this is a strong Bishop
this is a strong Bishop the rook is very
strong there are all sorts of threats
and black would be much better here so
here after work the g8 never plays f4
and it's really really a well thought
elaborate move a point being that after
the DF for 4 point is captured and this
thread is still introduced
you have h4 just blocking defending that
bishop and after B captors and c6 now
you have rope captors and i-4 and the
pressure on f6 is too great for black to
handle a fluke g6 now you can play Queen
f3 and if King g7 it looks very ugly but
if it works why not but it doesn't you
can just bring the knight into the game
and after rook a to f1 there will simply
be too much pressure on the night and f6
and the white to just wins so this is
the idea behind nipples f4 so here Fabi
goes B captures on c6 instead he grabs
the piece this way and now Queen to II
one no net was just threatening Queen to
h4 check King to g7 and Queen to h6
checkmate so Fabi has to do something
about this and he goes for the absolute
best move rook captures and g5 he gives
back some material so f captures and g5
and now Knight back to g8 so here as you
can see Naboo is still on the attack but
Bobby is able to hold back his forces
now all of Nepos pieces are still all
the way back so here rook captures on f7
with Czech and now if you go to h8 it's
just game over just Queen h4 Czech and
the King has no moves you have to give
up the night and then it's just a nice
checkmate either between h7 or queen to
g7 so here what Bobby did was King to g6
now attack the rook and now Knepper
brings it back rook to f3 and now Bobby
goes for ich actress on d4 he wants to
open up this dark square bishop and make
use of this diagonal so King to h1
played in great style by an echo he
gives gives up more points now and gets
rid of this pin here so now he can just
continue playing and point is you don't
really have a like like an entrance with
the Queen or something as long as this
Knight is here ng8 he covers both f8 and
h f6 and h6 and it's not easy for for
white to continue the attack so here
Fabi just goes for the comm Queen e7 who
wants to develop the Queen the bishop
and bring the rook into the game so as
if he can trade off a little bit of
White's attackers it should be very good
for him so nipple goes Knight d2 now
clearly says that now you can capture on
c3 as I cannot recapture with the night
which Fabi does so D captures be
captures and now Bishop to e6
and just that nicely developing
preparing to bring the rook into the
game and now Queen to h4 again it's not
easy for white to attack as the knight
is just a beautiful defender on g8 so
here Queen to h7 Fabi is interested in
trading as much as possible and now
Queen back to g3 and here Queen to h5
just bringing that Queen deeper into the
position now with even with ideas of
just capturing here on g5 so here Queen
to f4 and now asking black what do you
want to do here point is if you go for
something like this Queen captures and
g5 dentro g3 just wins the Queen so not
not possible at for the moment so King
to g7 now making room for the Queen and
g6 and also you might have some ideas of
shifting the bishop here to help out
with the defense however it's unlikely
you kind of want to keep your Bishop
over here so here we have rook a to f1
netwo brings a third attacker to the F
file and now rook to e8 at some point
you might be able to put some pressure
on the e pawn and Queen back to g3 so
here neppo I would guess is without
without an active plan and he's waiting
for Fabi to make her move
point is Fabi doesn't really have any
good moves with the bishop or or this
Bishop or with the rook the knight
cannot move really as you don't really
well not another Knight can move and now
the FOB you move that since now after
Queen to g3 was played I guess Naples
idea was the beta Fabi into developing
the night so he can make use of the f6
square so here far B does go for night
knife to e7 as the Queen no longer has
access to the f6 square and now rook to
f6 instantly played by neppo we have
Knight to g6 now and now Knight to f3
so disconnecting rooks for the moment
but it's not a problem as the Jeep on
nicely defends the rook and here while
Fabi could go for the a pawn right away
he first wants to go for Bishop to c4 he
wants to get this this rook away from
the F file as this Bishop also covers
the f2 square so sort of an in-between
move before capturing an a2 so here we
have looked the e1 and only now the spa
be capped Rani - creating a nice past a
pawn for himself
however the rook isn't all that
on the e-file nicely protecting the
e-pawn at some point you might even have
some nice support for your e upon push
if you ever decide to do so so here at
night study for Nepal now prepares to go
Knight to f5 check which could be
incredibly dangerous and for example if
you allow it let's say rookie 5 try and
get some pieces into the attack and now
let's say Knight f5 check blocking this
rook captures and now King h7 it's hard
to find a good way to continue for white
but after let's say h4 it's also not
easy to find a good way to continue for
black and would probably being very long
time it's not a position you want to
find yourself in so here Bobby says I'm
just gonna remove one of the attackers
so Bishop characters on d4 makes sense
we have C captures and now we have
Bishop the back to g8 so now I'm making
room for a pawn and now if the pawn
reaches a 2 and D a 2 square is guarded
by the bishop black should should easily
have a winning position as it will be
too much for whites to handle this
protected passport so here at nipple
goes for it
'if I've she creates a passport for
himself as well now Bobby doesn't want a
trade here instead he first goes Bishop
to b5 now puts a lot of pressure on this
diagonal for example if the black if the
White Queen wasn't here you could just
play Queen captures on h3 and it's game
over
due to the pin white will be unable to
recapture so here a nipple goes king h2
right away and now a5 Fabi starts
pushing his passport and now e 6 looks a
very compelling here you kind of want to
play it but it's hard to know where to
go from here probably something like
rookie 3 to keep an eye on the a3 square
maybe Queen f2 fall by rook f7 a lot of
ideas here however Knepper just goes for
rook to e3 he doesn't want to commit to
any pawn moves says Fabi you're a long
time you figure something out man and he
was rookie 3 which makes sense you give
more more protection to the third-ranked
also you're covering the a3 square which
is a dark square a very hard for black
to get over that square so here Phi
betrays once the captures we have D
captures and now well you could go for
something like rook the e6 to try and go
for a trade it's hard hard to say if
this is good for black as even if you
capture it
and you just allow captures here and it
becomes an even stronger passport so
hard to save this will be possible
however the move Fabi plays Queen to d2
allows neppo a really interesting idea
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find nipples move while I give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations on clearing the path for
the Queen and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's East six and
now the Queen is threatening to capture
here and if this happens it's just all
over so here what you want to do is rook
to e7 which is what Fabi did and how you
defend the c7 point but now comes Queen
f2 now with the threat of rook to f7
check so here
Fabi defended with night the h8 covering
the f7 square but here you could really
do a lot of things so feel free to pause
the video and win the game for white
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations is pretty much any move
here is winning and for those of you who
just want to enjoy show never played
rook to h6 however a much quicker win is
Queen to h4 Queen to h4 with the threat
of just Queen h6 fall by rook to f8
checkmate and there is no way to defend
against this for example if looked at e8
then just Queen h6 checking to g8 and
now okay you don't have checkmate but
after g6 it's just game over so this is
one way to go about it Napo decided to
go for a different path he played rook
to h6 which is basically the same the
same combination only the rook and
Queens which place is not the threat as
Queen f6 checking g8 and rook to h8
checkmate so here you could try
something like Queen to d4 to prevent
this Queen to f6 move but I also forgot
to mention it was in this position
unmoved 38 that Fabiana Caruana resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here but I will show you how the
line continues as it's really really
interesting so here you could defend
with Queen before not allowing this
check but now there are many ways you
could win this but I want you to find
the absolute coolest way to end the game
for white here while I give you a couple
of seconds for the third time in this
video so for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations and spotting
the the coolest way of ending this game
and for those of you who just wanna
enjoy show its Queen to f6 check really
really awesome waited and in the game
point is that now it's over you have to
accept the Queen otherwise its King g8
rotate a checkmate
or just Queen it no not finish yet as
the Queen is now here buddy I just came
here and rook captures will be checkmate
so here you have to capture capture this
comes with check this is defended so you
have to capture the rook and now of
course comes F captures on e7 and there
is no way to stop this point from
queening so that is definitely the
coolest way to do it now but after work
h6 v you saw that there's no way of
doing anything here and he will also had
like 4 seconds on the clock so of course
he resigned the game interestingly
nipple head like some 5 minutes left on
the clock so this is a one game that he
really really played well and it seems
that Fabi just ran into his beautiful h3
preparation and this is what happened
here so very interesting and yeah what
do you guys think will this or all of
this this amount of beautiful games
played on a daily basis is now for
example we're having this tournament the
chest will Masters 2020 which lasts for
like 2 or 3 weeks and every day we will
have like 2 or 3 beautiful games like
this how will how will classical games
or classical chests survive when they
you know again start when we will again
have over the board chest when we will
have 5 to 6 hour games that will more
often than not end in a draw will
classical chests like you know regain
its former glory or will we just have to
rely more and more on online chess on
rapid chess on blitz games and and so on
so what do you guys think about that but
yeah yeah once again I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank the
Turkish carpet George needs his wildon
Paget Thomas Connors and the man orange
and Mishra for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check too
in my previous video serum thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the chest
bull masters checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world also the
podcast with hiigara Nakamura is coming
soon so thank you I will see soon and
have an excellent rest your day